humans will travel to Mars within the
next couple of decades that's according
to NASA anyway
the ultimate goal to live entirely
independent of Earth
scientists are already developing
technology that will enable us to travel
the incredibly long distances and Keep
Us Alive when we get there but if we
really want to inhabit other worlds a
major issue needs to be addressed
can we reproduce in space
if humans had a base on Mars we couldn't
keep popping back 225 million kilometers
a journey likely to take around seven
months to have children on Earth humans
will need to have babies in space
is a hostile environment for the human
body with high levels of radiation
something both sperm and egg cells are
highly sensitive to
NASA recently sent the first samples of
Frozen human sperm to space the Frozen
cells were successfully reactivated but
showed DNA damage and moved differently
which would likely reduce their chances
of fertilizing an egg
more encouragingly freeze-dried Mouse
sperm that spent several months in space
produced a brood of healthy pups when
fertilized back on Earth
although the sperm DNA had changed the
damage was repaired upon contact with
the female egg for a fetus to develop in
space however it would need to be
protected from this harmful radiation
its rapid growth rate would make a baby
particularly vulnerable to genetic
mutations increasing the risk of
childhood cancers and perhaps as
significant as radiation in the long
term is time spent away from Earth's
gravity we know that low gravity causes
astronauts muscles to atrophy bones to
become less dense and the quantity of
circulating blood in the body to
decrease the first baby born off-planet
Earth will most likely be born on Mars
where gravity is about 38 of Earth's
which is bound to affect both birth and
development but if a child was born in
microgravity for example on a space
station the impacts would be much more
pronounced for the sake of argument
let's imagine this happening
it's thought that gravity helped shape
parts of the inner ear that play an
important role in balance and
orientation rat pops born after
developing in space couldn't sense which
way was up or down and microgravity
would continue to pose challenges for
childbirth itself on Earth there is
always the option of a C-section but
although Medics have mended rat's tales
and performed Keyhole surgery on pigs no
one has ever been operated on in space
blood can spatter even more than it
usually does on Earth floating around
unconstrained by gravity or it can pull
into a kind of Dome around a wound
making it hard to see what's going on
today if an astronaut needs emergency
surgery they have to ditch their mission
and return to Earth
but presuming the birth was successful a
baby growing up in microgravity would
look move and behave very differently to
one born on Earth there a child would
not learn to crawl but would instead
learn to float propelling themselves
using their arms without a strict
exercise regime it's possible their
bones and muscles would be smaller in
their lower body yet bigger and stronger
in their upper body like astronauts
fluids in their body could travel
upwards into their chest and head giving
them a puffy face as a result a child
born and raised in space might never be
able to live on Earth it's possible they
might not be able to walk stand or even
breathe
Earth's gravity is so important to
humans that it's been described as the
identity of mankind without it would a
human subspecies emerge only able to
survive in space
assuming all the physical challenges can
be overcome there are other issues that
would need to be considered what would
be the impacts of raising a child in
such an isolated and extreme environment
while a mother may be able to consent
the child cannot
is it ethical to raise human beings who
may never be able to set foot on planet
Earth
right now having a baby in space may
feel like something from a sci-fi film
But ultimately it's a puzzle we have to
solve if we want to travel deeper into
our solar system
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video